according to multiple reports arnold
schwarzenegger and maria shriver are
officially divorced more than 10 years
after maria's initial filing it's great
it's great
the couple met in 1977 and tied the knot
in 1986.
eti was actually outside the church on
their big day
[Applause]
they were married for 25 years and share
four children together
well i think whenever arnold speaks
people are always
interested in what he has to say maria
was seen by arnold's side during his
campaign for governor of california in
2003 i think it's great that all these
people come out and take time out of
their day and you know come out here to
cheer arnold on months after his term
ended arnold and maria announced their
separation in may 2011.
controversy struck days later when it
was revealed arnold admitted to
fathering a secret son 14 years earlier
the mother was a longtime employee of
their household staff schreiber first
filed for divorce on june 1st 2011
citing irreconcilable differences
but the exes have remained on friendly
terms frequently appearing together with
their kids at public events you get
along really well arnold opened up to et
in 2012 about their separation we have a
great time raising the kids together and
so you know it's it's really an end the
most important thing is that the kids
are doing well
and maria always has been an
extraordinary mother and always has
worked with the kids very closely i was
always more off
working and being on location and she
was doing the work and so together we
always were a good team in that
[Music]
you